moi ce n'est pas trop peur au niveau
psychologique on a peur au niveau des
radiations et c'est vrai que les
radiations il faudra vraiment sont
occupés de façon très sérieuse avant
qu'on puisse y aller il ya différents
scénarios et le scénario à six mois mais
si vous prenez un scénario du type
d'asie me c'est un moteur qui va accéder
en permanence sur la moitié du chemin
vers mars
et on peut faire le voyage en mode 3
mois dans ce cas là vous décoller avant
la distance la plus courte entre entre
mars et la terre vous faites trois mois
pour y aller trois mois sur place un peu
le retour on peut tourner en neuf mois
sur vh1 mars mais le beau temps désigne
en existe au sol fonctionne dans le vide
je le connais bien ce montant là il n'a
jamais volé dans l'espace dont tu vas
encore quelques dizaines d'années pour
le faire tout ce dès maintenant sur des
vols de six mois et sur ma résistance
psychologique ce qu'on a mis au point
pour les astronautes dans l'iss est
aujourd'hui et qui fonctionne très très
bien c'est un entraînement spécial qu'on
appelle un traitement analogique qu'on
appelle hdp pour human behaviour la
performance et l'habileté
comportementale qui est fait en sortant
les gens de leur zone de confort par des
entraînements autre que les simulateurs
technique donc on les maires en montagne
sous l'eau sous terre dans le grand
froid et dans des régions de survie et
tous les ados d'aujourd'hui de l'esab
également le partenaire de la station
spatiale fond cet entraînement là et on
s'est rendu compte que avec un bon choix
des candidats au niveau psychologique
plus cet entraînement qui va aller faire
plus résistant et bien ils vont
supporter au niveau psychologique
beaucoup plus les les grandes absences
delà de la terre de leurs amis de leur
famille maintenant après il ya toute la
structure à mettre en place aussi à
calculer donc ça va pas se faire tout de
suite
il y a appris également et j'aime bien
quand on parle tout prix remettre les
choses en place si on prend l'exemple de
la tour spatiale européenne
si on considère tout ce qu'on a fait
pour les vols habités au niveau des
astronautes européens qui concerne la tp
columbus et les autres européens
eh bien nous ça ne revient à 1 euro par
an et par européen donc c'est pas une
somme énorme de sur la paille notre
accès à nous mais toute cette
organisation pour marteau mois elle ne
peut pas se faire avec un seul pays
c'est vraiment
a besoin d'être en collaboration
complète avec la chine les etats unis la
russie et même là ainsi deux européens
et les partenaires de 10 à 16
[Musique]